dying like 2 has a huge weekend batman
arkham collection for switch may have
leaked and more
dying light 2 stay human is doing very
well on pc reaching nearly 275
000 p concurrent players on steam right
out the gate that's a massive result
that makes the open world zombie game
one of steam's most played games at that
number dying light 2 achieved more than
6 times the peak concurrent player count
for the original dying light the sequel
now sits at number 23 on the all-time
list for highest peak concurrent players
on steam these impressive numbers are
all despite the game's buggy launch that
has included issues with co-op as well
as crazy spinning heads just to name a
few dying light 2 is also available on
playstation and xbox consoles but that
player data for those platforms are not
yet available a nintendo switch version
of the game is coming later this year
and speaking of switch batman arkham
collection has potentially leaked for
the console and it appears set to launch
later this year french retailer wtt has
a listing for batman arkham collection
for nintendo switch for 60 euros with
the release date of august 31st warner
bros has not confirmed the game for
nintendo's hybrid console however so
it's best to approach this one with
skepticism until it does that being said
vgc has pointed out that the same
retailer also listed the witcher 3 the
wild hunt for nintendo switch before its
official announcement so there could be
a solid chance that the arkham
collection leak is real considering
august 31st lanes on a wednesday however
it could just be a placeholder date
and while it's unclear when the
playstation vr2 will launch it's a safe
bet that psvr2 pre-orders will sell out
very quickly if you're a playstation 5
owner anxiously awaiting the next gen vr
headset you should sign up for sony's
mailing list that just went live on the
official playstation website sony will
send playstation vr to news including
details on when you can pre-order
directly to your inbox as revealed at
ces the psvr 2 has an oled display
capable of running games in 4k at hdr up
to 102 hertz the headset uses sony sense
technology which includes precise inside
out tracking powered by tiny cameras
perhaps most notably the ps vr2 has eye
tracking which intends to add another
layer of immersion the brand new sense
controllers have finger touch detection
a motion sensor and haptic feedback the
headset itself also offers haptic
feedback the first playstation vr is
home to many great experiences most of
which were reviewed pretty well these
games include titles like moss blood and
truth as well as astrobot rescue mission
so have you been playing dying light 2
and are you excited to play batman on
switch possibly let me know in the
comments
[Music]